e queste
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
facciamo scherzi è notte fonda
sono riuscito a chiudere unità nella
tenda si può sapere perché mi hai
rifiuto qua dentro perché sei pericolosa
ma stavolta sì è vero se pericolosa e
c'è la luna piena oggi è sicuramente 6
pericolosa per me ma magari tu sei anche
per gli altri quindi è meglio se sei
vuoi il consiglio che mi ha dato il lupo
e ti tempo gli usa fa dentro e va bene
allora se vi fa il listino è di prometto
che non ti mangerò no non ti credo che
lo giuro non ti credo comunque non può
passare tutto il tempo chiusa qua dentro
così per come se vuoi stare
e invece no rimarrai chiusa fa dentro si
chiama un passare a luna piena e arriva
il mattino io usa che adesso vi faccio
anche un pisolino no devi rimanere qua
dentro del detto che c'è sono qui e ti
sei addormentato non ho fame si no ti ho
detto di no ti devo sorvegliare devo
rimanere sveglio tutta la notte ma
perché che cosa succederà quando arriva
alla luna piena
niente non succederà niente mi sento mi
sento un po strana che senso strada sta
succedendo qualcosa che cosa sta
succedendo
guarda è meglio che aprì la tenda c'è
qualcosa di strano non ne sono così
sicuro non è che mi sta ingannando no no
io l'avrò la tenda si trasfusione di
quel punto a piedi avvicinati
miopia scappo scappo scappò anita
cercato di farmi attraverso la tenda ma
so io come sistemarla adesso la sistemo
io adesso con questi i paletti per la
tenda ora visto la tenda così la vita
non potrà più scappare nemmeno con la
tenda piano le dita che cosa stai
facendo niente sto schiacciando le noci
voi ma no c'è in tutti i rumori strani
che cosa stai facendo è un martello si
sta aprendo le noci col martello dai
fissando la tenda al terreno
per azione
ora non potrei scappare più da nessuna
parte
hai visto l'artista va bene se non credo
così forse mi rimetto questo paletto che
cosa no no no no theatre niente solo
adesso non andrà da nessuna parte
[Musica]
vero
cosa
sta succedendo
all
[Musica]
o no sta succedendo
o no la trasformazione è incominciata
non sono riuscito a tenerla nico lupo
mannaro chiuso nella tenda e adesso che
cosa farà scapperà e cercherà di
mangiarmi oppure andrà alla ricerca di
altre persone magari no non so che cosa
devo fare
ma
[Musica]
è enorme che cosa facciamo adesso
sembra stai venendo qui dentro casa con
no adesso mi mangio che cosa devo fare
[Musica]
per nino marino tocchi su un cane
aiutami e lupo mannaro nella sua forma
massima che cosa dobbiamo fare adesso
scappiamo ci prenderà ci mangiano
sta arrivando
[Musica]